[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's the Monday after a holiday we
started the show and did the first 15
minutes of the show before he realized
we weren't alive
it's gone forever
but but yeah so everything you're about
to hear is well rehearsed okay welcome
back uh coming up on today's episode
we've got a lot to talk about Ant-Man
Gonna Die
James Gunn uh ruins uh Jessica's a video
right now
it's still a good theory we're going to
talk about it
Bob Iger uh did to Bob chapic what uh we
did to the beginning
uh and what that means about Disney plus
and the future of Marvel and Star Wars
on Disney plus and then um we've got
some interesting stuff about Spider-Man
4. potential next Spider-Man movie
um but first let's welcome our wonderful
guests who are well seasoned in their
chairs by now speaking of seasoning uh
Jay Washington's here
never talking about it before
hi uh to y'all again for the first time
or something like that uh we talked
about hoping Thanksgiving was great we
found out Jessica don't you seasoning
and she cooked chicken like the white
ladies on Atlanta
I said this earlier
but I didn't really catch that I also
just realized now this woman is the only
fans page I understand
it's Jessica Clemens is here uh
unhinging jaws and John Grant is here
jaw firmly
okay but uh again we gotta we gotta hop
right into stuff real quick we're so
late uh if you're in Los Angeles or
you're planning on being at La Comic Con
we new Rockstar's the break room is
going to be at La Comic Con we're doing
a live show Sunday December 4th that's
this upcoming Sunday 10 30 a.m uh at La
Comic-Con uh uh myself is going to be
there Jessica's gonna be there John's
going to be there Eric Voss is going to
be there Brandon Barrick Tommy Bechtel
maybe a couple other folks you'll
recognize from the expanded new rock
stars Universe
um but swing by and say hey we'd love to
see you
I'll be dressed up oh Jessica's dressing
up she teasing earlier yeah thank you
thank you for the retake
hey in an interview Empire magazine
director of Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania discussed how Kang in this
movie is different than the amp uh in
Loki right he was like King the
Conqueror and our movie is very
different character Reed goes on to say
he's someone who has dominion over time
he's a warrior and a strategist
so uh
I'll recap most of this article he goes
on to so to say like it in previous
anime movies the villains were like
lesser right you got yellow jacket
you've got ghosts shots fired shots
fired at his own movies
damn yeah but then he said this is an
opportunity to have Ant-Man face a quote
Alzheimer antagonist and
some of the things that I was saying
before
this episode started with like you know
um
uh we were talking when the first
announcement came out for quantumania we
were like
Ant-Man
and Kang really yeah King is the next
Thanos you think we've been told right
Kang Dynasty he's the plan for the whole
next phase and they're gonna introduce
him in an Ant-Man and you know it's like
Ant-Man he's got his like sort of own
kind of corner of the MCU those films
are a little lighter on tone they're a
little bit more fun they're a little bit
more funny
um and it was just like a weird thing we
were all sitting there like it feels
weird that he's gonna be introduced in
an Ant-Man movie so what if and I like
where I don't know if you want to you
should summarize the rest of the article
before I say this sure sure uh the
article then goes on to sort of like
Loosely imply that Scott Lang might not
be long for the MCU
um we know from the trailer that was
shown at d23 Kang says you know you're
an offender haven't killed you before
I'm kind of implying that like hey it's
definitely possible that can't kill
these guys so this article was really
interesting
the very last line of it said something
like you know Scott Lang may not be able
to enjoy his Quantum Mania of Solace
like a weird word play on Quantum of
Solace in in quantumania
um basically implying that Scott likes
to die in this movie right
um so well and we were we were kind of
just speculating in the the pre-show
that we thought was the actual show that
like what a way to introduce a big bad
and you know every Marvel property has
villains right that come and go every
Disney plus series everything but to
establish wow this is a Next Level
villain this is like a game changer this
is somebody that's going to take a bunch
of movies all the Avengers are gonna
have to come together to defeat them and
by having Kang kill
Scott Lang the dude whose movie it is
more specifically killed the the
protagonist of the movie not just like
give me a different story we're saying
kill Scott Lang in another film just
kill Scott and Lang in his movie in
front of Cassie because we know Cassie
gets her suit and everything so he if
Kane kills uh can't kill Scotland in
front of Cassie we don't get no more
Scott Lane podcast that he can step on
the WASP we all are just clapping like I
said we'll have a Bravo moment we all
will agree but it also lets you know
this is a dangerous cane yes and then
there's still other variants of King
that are dangerous yeah what if he just
gets taken into the quantum realm and he
can't get back out yeah they do a little
Switcheroo Kang stuck in there now and
he's like you're gonna be stuck in there
it seems like yeah because we haven't
perfected reaching into the quantum
realm clearly because in the trailer we
see Cassie like just get sucked in and
no one ever really figured out that
actually works well I I do like and I
think there's definitely potential for
something like that where they can kind
of retire Ant-Man but still kind of he's
there if we need him
um
playing podcasts in the quantum realm no
no
it's so quiet
a big amplifier but um I was gonna say
like again not only does this establish
King as like wow what a threat he killed
our beloved comedic hero an OG Avenger
right like it's been around for a while
wow this guy is legit especially Marvel
doesn't kill especially Heroes right
like we have yet to see that really
simple right because he starts
yes but they still died yeah but they're
sacrificing we haven't seen anybody be
murdered
can you imagine as a fan and we already
know Kang Dynasty you know we know
King's gonna be around for years at this
point before he's maybe hopefully
eventually defeated or whatever so like
wow what a way to set the table like you
just killed Ant-Man and I'm not gonna
get revenge you know what I mean like we
freaking hours we know can I ask you a
question
I guess how important and this is a
cold-hearted question I shouldn't ask it
but I'm being brave right now
um if he died do you lose a lot of
attachment how close are you to Ant-Man
because that's why I don't think what
I know you're joking
I would be really sad I'd be sad if a
lot of like mantis died but like because
Ant-Man in normal situations no one
gives a [ __ ] about for lack of better
words this Ant-Man and Paul Rudd and
what he's done you've become attached to
yes so you think them like I also say
well sorry just to answer your question
there Jessica doesn't it feel like
Marvel has been purposefully placing a
lot of Ant-Man all over the place
Guardians holiday special who's there in
front of the Chinese Theater there's an
Ant-Man character uh Kamala Khan right
listens to the podcast they've been
squeezing him in a lot because I think
they want to remind us like oh yeah this
guy has been around for a while he was
in Civil War he was in the you know I
took it as they're trying to get you to
like him more I thought I took it as
like as a reminder but it's not a
winning meal right and I do think like
maybe that if this is gonna happen
that's the job of quantumania to like
get us yeah you know and like to see him
as a family man and like be invested in
him again you know uh and to like kind
of feel that he's important before maybe
ripping him away and you're sure he
won't be like Janet it won't be hope let
me lay down the breadcrumbs for why I
think it's gonna be okay right okay
um in the quantumania trailer they sit
there and they say Scott now is a public
figure right he's both a superhero and a
celebrity
um not too many of those people exist in
the MCU we haven't seen like celebrity
in the MCU to a degree I think right
obviously like a lot of those characters
have their had their face exposed Tony
Stark obviously I'm Iron Man but like we
don't we don't see the repercussions of
That Celebrity very often he's a
celebrity
um we also know that they're setting up
some characters to be able to do things
that Scott can do right not only can
Cassie stature grow big and small but
like she also is creating Quantum
devices to get into the quantum realm so
if you need someone like that in Kang
Dynasty we have an option right I'll
also say they're setting up a Fantastic
Four movie to come out and I think that
if you kill
Scott Lang in this movie you can replace
all of the science stuff that you need
him to do with a reason and he's
technically never been he's not the guy
anyway he's right Hank is the science
guy but yeah but you know he Quantum
realm and collecting all these particles
you know he was in there for five years
you know he might have learned a lot I'm
gonna assume but here's one thing too
this would be the first movie he's
actually fully happy
yeah yeah absolutely the first movie he
just gets out of his family he just gets
out of prison he's trying to see his
daughter the second movie he's on house
arrest the whole time dealing with all
that this one he's a free dude living
life he has the woman he loves and his
daughter Scott blank is actually happy
in this movie yeah hey so that that's
the arc right from like I'm just getting
out of prison I'm unhappy and I'm kind
of finding my journey I'm finding my
path by becoming a hero yeah he's
starting out things are going good he's
a hero Journey Into Darkness I think
it's Cassie's Hero Journey so I mean
that's the only way well you ever hear
it's her well this is her Obi-Wan she
has to die or Judy Greer has to die but
also hopes both of her parents are also
still alive so that's why I think it's
more we're gonna see Hank or Jake I want
to see Hank try to grow and then have a
heart attack like that would be waiting
in the suit
any of those characters but like hope
dying doesn't have quite the same impact
right an Avenger was killed right most
importantly right this is the third
movie in the trilogy right I know that
Marvel isn't doing traditional three
movie arcs that often although I would
argue they did it sort of with
Spider-Man and then hit the reset button
they've done it obviously Iron Man uh
with Iron Man
like can we really count I know and then
he had a bunch of Avengers movies
but you know Guardians of the Galaxy
volume three is definitely gonna be the
end yeah yeah and Paul red 79 years old
yeah okay looks great it looks great
incredible
he's a 187 years old forever
Cassie and I'm gonna be like oh but I
think I don't think you killed stature
because I think you're building no I did
that I was just like no don't don't
think I don't want to believe that
because they killed Cassie I think
because that would again that would
shock people even more than killing
Scott Lane because everything has been
the MC he has been setting up to build
this next batch of Avengers from the
kids
like you get casting you got the twins
you got Kamala Khan you're getting all
the younger groups if you kill Cassie
out of nowhere everybody's like whoa I'm
the only one in there why'd you recaster
someone has to die did they the old
Cassie they had her do a screen test
dying and they're like she doesn't die
well since we were running a little late
uh unfortunately we cut this discussion
off a little early I want to go through
a couple more things we learned about
quantumania first of all David that's
malcian oh God yeah uh is coming back
but uh no TI No Michael Pena
coming back
you can you can Google that to find out
why to find out why the pain is not
going to come back uh companion we'll
all miss that I mean great bits in in uh
I wonder in every movie where the other
guys want to do though maybe he'll just
he shows up he shows he's the cops he's
a comedic relief he shows up and he sees
the quantum realm and he's gonna pawn it
or something and then it's a race
against both times
Point
um and then in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter separate interview
Jonathan Majors was uh talking about a
bunch of the films she was doing and he
says no spoilers here but there are so
many variants of him and with the powers
that are the MCU he's talking about like
the people who work at Marvel that
Intelligentsia and that Brain Trust
there they're really working to use IP
the best of its ability and it's
extremely humbling that they picked me
to step into that so I'm honored to do
it and I'm always excited to see what
we're doing and I just wanted to bring
that up because I don't think it had
been confirmed yet that we were going to
see multiple Kang variants in this
particular movie one do you think that's
not really we're gonna see multiple King
variants eventually I don't think so you
know I don't think I don't think we get
that because it seems like it's the
belief is that I'm sorry that makes it
real quick the belief is we're going to
start getting him in every movie almost
because now again various variants I
don't think he pops up that much
I think he pops up just a little bit
more than Thanos did yeah because
remember we got the first thing at the
end of Avengers and then Guardians of
the Galaxy was like oh he's here for
real and then so you start having that
but I think we just get a little bit
more I don't think he's every single
movie because then it's like what is he
doing yeah dancing well we're going to
talk about we're going to talk about one
very unlikely place that Kang might
appear uh in the MCU later but first I
think we wanted to think so our friends
over at epic hero shop yeah so um our
friends at epic hero who make uh fun
merch including like uh this shirt that
I'm wearing or the shirts no not that
shirt
I like that shirt
villain we'll get you one
they have this new thing they're calling
it a con vest and Khan is in convention
and it's a it's a vest they they think
like you can wear this all the time but
specifically maybe you wear it to a
convention maybe you were to uh Star
Wars celebration WonderCon wherever you
want to go
um it's got some fun details on it like
they're they're little words text here
written at the top some of this is
orabesh from Star Wars some of this is
wakandan some of this is um the language
of the elves from Lord of the Rings
Cimarron or something like that but all
these fun little details in a plane
exactly well that's because it's
customizable to your own specification
set them up maybe you want to put some
fun pins in here they also sell these
pins they got like a Loki Gator pin a
fun one that says sorcerer in the
Supreme font don't sue them
um yeah you know and black panther one
and you can even get a new rockstars pin
maybe you put on a patch like there's
some of the patches they have boom boom
We this week we're going to be
customizing this particular vest with
pins and patches I'll add the break room
and even have break room hosts are going
to sign it somewhere and then we're
gonna do a giveaway for this exact yeah
uh best go to that uh URL that's on the
screen right now and we'll also be in
the description of this video
um yes contest yeah and you can um
convest contest you can throw your email
in there and you can enter to win that
bad boy
um again we love to give it away and
that way maybe uh you won't get it in
time for La Comic Con this year but
maybe at San Diego Comic Con next year
which we'll also be at we'll spot you in
this and give you a super sick high five
yes it's the holidays right and most of
us aren't eating great I know I have
finished the leftovers from Thanksgiving
so that tells you how my uh reading has
been uh over the last few weeks my main
food groups were the mashed potatoes and
stuffing well we need some help really
too because my arteries are clogged uh
and that's where he1 is coming in hey
you know I didn't have I the salad's
still in the fridge
thank you thank you for being honest
guys nobody is pushing aside the mashed
potatoes and gravy or the pumpkin pie to
reach for the salad nobody is nobody is
John says
still enjoy your leftovers
and a glass of water and you're covered
for your vitamins and nutrient needs
you're investing in an online nutrition
insurance for less than the price of a
latte okay uh if so if you're saving a
little bit of money after spending a ton
on Thanksgiving food like I did Jesus
Christ Thanksgiving is expensive the
cheese comes at this table okay you
should you should see the the
charcuterie budget that some of these
people are throwing out I love it
speaking of which this is dairy-free
uh it's also keto uh it's paleo it's
vegan and of course it's gluten-free as
well um so but the cool thing too is
that your subscription comes with a
year's supply of vitamin D I got to tell
you when I had my last physical my
doctor was like the one supplement that
you should be taking every single day is
vitamin D really I was like you couldn't
just go out in the sun more and he was
like well then you're gonna like ruin
your skin yeah melanoma and all that
kind of stuff so vitamin D super
important uh we need these things in the
winter months when we don't get as much
sunlight really good for you so reclaim
your health and arm your immune system
with convenient daily nutrition and to
make it easy athletic greens is going to
offer you one free supply of immune
supporting vitamin D and five free
travel bags which are Super convenient I
think some of us just keep them in our
car if we're like running late and we
just need to put something in our body
um so all you have to do visit
athleticgreens.com break room super easy
to remember uh again that's
athleticgreens.com break room to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutrition thank you
to Athleta green I have a question yes
how can the sun kill you basically it's
supposed to help you at the same time
let's say isn't that messed up like the
light of God what's the ultimate villain
besides
and the ultimate hero you guys want to
know I love real Ultimate villain is
it's James Gunn and let me tell you why
oh I'm so mad at it I'm so mad okay
either way you're probably watching this
James and I hope you are because I'm on
the show James I will box
yeah guardians of the galaxies uh
holiday special drops and we are going
to be spoiling it like right now so just
as a I'll give you like three seconds
like there it is okay so the story
focuses on Christmas yes but after
Thanos is attacked uh nowhere they
brought it back from they bought it back
from The Collector it was a burnt out
husk and they've been rebuilding it ever
since I guess and it looks perfect it's
great I'm very happy about it if you
hear my tone it's only because I'm mad
about this one part James Gunn took to
Twitter in the humblest of ways and shot
down my nebula stealing Bucky's arm
theories so he didn't go directly for me
he just said two he responded to someone
saying
um she had tore it off his body because
she was overwhelmed with Christmas
spirit that was James guns James said
for the viewers at home who maybe
haven't seen your video yet what was
your theory my fear it's fake it's not a
real it wasn't though it's not a it's a
replica okay yeah it's not a real arm I
think she made it because this person is
she makes her own Parts she's been
rebuilt by mechanical pieces all the
time
um I there's a million ways this could
go but I genuinely am like there's no
way she went to Earth where they just
came up with the idea of Christmas and
gift giving and stole Bucky's arm we
don't know what she was doing while
mantis and Drax were out here in two
hours yesterday
show me the ship show me the ship and
the ship that can pinpoint where Bucky
is on the planet oh yeah because we
don't know we don't know and it makes
hey what about
see James again this is the kind of
violence you can expect
I didn't sign up for black on black
crime
actually it's in Europe it's in your
writing
but but you know he did write it he did
direct it he can say whatever he wants
and we as the people that we are in the
rockstars have to go off of this is
really important right do we as we rock
stars and fans of Marvel right we're
fans first
is this kid is James Gunn's Twitter
you know
yeah exactly he makes a candidate he
will tell you that once he says yo this
is what it is we unfortunately like you
just said we have no choice but to
accept it and he can do it because he's
leaving he's already in his other thing
is in post he's genuinely leaving he's
like this is whoever's going to the next
person well and I do love it we know
we're getting more Bucky in the future
he's on that Thunderbolts poster and
he's on the Thunderbolts poster with his
arm yeah
you did a good job pointing out the
exact bicep parts and the light off of
it reflects completely differently and I
use the arm that he went to like the
Party part and Falcon won her soldier
that has a bunch of different lights
bouncing off of it completely different
it's a different it's a different finish
it's a different like it is whatever and
you know we saw we saw him receive the
arm from the wakanda yes originally and
we saw uh
yeah do the Kill Bill to his arms
somewhere back in whatever apartment
Bucky has right if he doesn't have a
closet full of arm options and those are
the things that's what
I can't you think the wakandans are like
here's an article we don't know we don't
know that this arm is vibranium I did
say I did I did mention maybe it could
be something from Hydra that was either
stolen or taken because it's they're
basically like people that just through
the Galaxy you'll meet different
versions of anything so there's probably
someone that stole it from Hydra and is
in space and the nebula has taken it off
of them I was like that is the only
other there's a lot of theories and but
we're gonna have to start making them
because what James Gunn says it is I
just want to see a closet he opens up
and hang it up
there needs to be a situation
um where Bucky and nebula do actually
communicate because I'm like you guys
both are sharing the same situation you
guys can talk you can be like this is
what I do for my arm this is what you do
for your arm yeah um you think there was
like a little white elephant gift
exchange where nebula did yeah you
didn't rip off the arms
two things the last time we saw Bucky he
was a little unlucky in love he was
struggling to date a little thing could
that be could that be I love you I mean
maybe like he's a little part robot
she's a lot of part robots
and he wanted a woman of color so you
can get a blue one
we also met Cosmic we also met what
hospital Jane you I can't I'd give it to
you right now
he's back on the show tomorrow no he's
not
uh we also met Cosmo the dog who James
Gunn said is based off of Leica the
Soviet space dog who died in orbit in 57
but clearly this one didn't this one
didn't this one didn't so we'll just
live off this he says going back to the
original Source material and also
Whitney will be doing a breakdown on
Cosmo the dog uh on sun that will
premiere on our channel on Sunday so I
won't get too much into it but uh we'll
see him deliver a lot more rat treats
gun also goes into the Hall um it goes
into how the holiday special sets up
volume three he says I also think it was
kind of necessary because you know I'm
actually working in a lot of Mythology
that's going to be important in volume
three the fact that we had Cosmo the dog
the fact that they have this amazing
spaceship called the Bowie that's four
stories tall in real life they've
brought no they've bought nowhere from
The Collector that's their home base now
all of these things are important to
volume three you think they're gonna
destroy it did anybody know that the
collector owned nowhere I didn't realize
that that was the thing that shocked me
well okay so I think it and it crosses
it crosses so often I'm like was this in
the comics or was it in the first
guardians but it is like he mined it so
that makes sense that he was the first
one there and took it okay um but I
didn't know that he could just sell it
would you like to put in his head
I love that he was like this museum is
no longer in existence before I have no
purpose here yes take my husk dude how
many other head planets might he own who
knows right sure do you think they're
gonna destroy nowhere oh huh it's their
home base unless that's how they retire
destroys nowhere
it's the it's the head of a celestial
yeah I mean you make up a good point
right we can kind of understand how
Cosmo is going to play into volume three
with you know rocket trying to figure
out like where he comes from and a whole
like you know the high evolutionary
stuff having another talking animal is
certainly going to be helpful for that
we can kind of figure out like okay they
need a new ship it's called the belly
that makes sense to me moving on from
that but this whole like this is their
home base
they've never needed a home base no why
would they right like yes James gone on
Twitter also said like uh in between
movies they've been doing sort of like
odd jobs as like mercenaries they've
been doing Guardians of the Galaxy type
show ravager types yeah
so so you know maybe that's their home
base they like finish a mission they
come home but like I love it how does
that play into volume three
they were doing that at the beginning of
volume two remember when they were had
to defeat the monster but then they
stole rocket stole the batteries so
they've always have been doing those
little missions and stuff so that's not
but like you said to have a stabilized
base like yo this is if you want the
Guardians it's also too dangerous for
them because they make enemies along the
way all the time in all their movies and
then you're gonna have a home base like
easy to find one maybe it's not easy
also can we talk about the fact that
Drax has had way too much sodium in this
special
let him it's Thanksgiving big weekend
for David Batista also in Glass Onion
that John and I really enjoyed but um I
enjoyed it check that out uh Jessica is
gonna have a video coming out about
Glass Onion very soon tweet yes and and
for folks that didn't catch it I think
it's already out of the theaters it's
just this weekend a week so I think we
might still have you have a couple days
and then everybody will get to watch it
on Netflix next month so if you don't if
you didn't see it save Jessica's video
for later here's how I feel about this
go see it in the theater if you can
right it was so we were talking it was
so fun to see if you're coming back from
spoiler we're talking about Knives Out
Glass Onion it was so fun to see this
movie in the theater where like I had
maybe picked up on things before some
other people did and then like the
people next to me had like oh they had
put the pieces together or someone in
the front row like gasped on a line and
that made me go like wait what did that
mean it's so fun to see the movie in the
theater and then when it's on Netflix
you're going to want to re-watch it
because it does the whole like you know
Murder Mystery and you can watch it with
your mom or your cousin or whatever
there's two lines in the movie where I
still don't know what the words mean
they've made a point to talk about super
fun especially hey if you've already
seen wakanda forever twice you got your
avatar weight of the water tickets
go go see a Glass Onion okay but
speaking of uh streaming and the future
of streaming so since we last had a
break room episode
[ __ ] has hit the fan over at Disney HQ
okay Bob chapic who had been the CEO of
Disney for the last two years boom gets
fired and replaced by the guy that he
replaced Bob Iger okay Bob Iger and if
if you don't follow the kind of the back
of the house machinations of big media
companies right he long time ahead of
Disney he's the guy that bought Marvel
he's the guy that bought lucasfilm he's
the guy I think that technically bought
Pixar yeah yeah so like he built he Fox
he's the guy that launched Disney plus
he's the guy that kind of built the
monster that is Disney and then had the
smarts to get out right before the
pandemic hit what did you know about
literally I saw an article that was he
because you know we started first
hearing news about the pandemic in like
January and I think I saw an article
when chapik was fired that like Iger was
like I might want to get out before this
pandemic thing happened and you know in
this news has impacts obviously on Parks
and stockholders blah blah blah blah
blah we don't care about that we care
about our babies Marvel and Star Wars
especially okay and even more
specifically he he had a kind of his
first day officially on the job today he
did a town hall meeting just for all
Disney employees and of course we got
out to the press all the things that he
said
um and he dropped one line that's very
intriguing to us he talked about work
from home and politics and all this
other kind of stuff but one line
specifically about their streaming
strategy and a reminder obviously they
own Disney plus they also own ESPN plus
yes but he said that their strategy
going forward for streaming is to look
towards profitability instead of chasing
subscriber growth now I want to add yes
no no so well we're gonna we're gonna
pull this apart because I think there's
a lot of different ways to interpret
this and John and I were just talking
about this is Bob Iger is a very smart
man he would have only come back if he
had a very specific plan for Disney and
so there's a lot to this sentence that
we will probably find out over the next
month's year is whatever but we're gonna
try to speculate and guess what it means
right now so quick background
um Disney all other streaming stuff is
currently losing a bunch of money that
was the plan that they were going to
lose money for years until they they'll
just spend a ton Marvel shows and Star
Wars Shores and shows and all this other
kind of stuff uh sell people very cheap
subscriptions get them on board then
over time raise the rates whatever and
it will become profitable well that has
not happened and it's actually going a
little slower than they'd originally
thought it's actually losing more money
than they hoped it would lose yada yada
so as part of that and this is part of
the reason Bob Chapin got fired part of
that they are they're about to raise the
rates normal Disney plus is going to go
from eight bucks to 11 bucks you can
stay at eight bucks if you take ads on
your Disney plus as James was just
mentioning
um they're doing some other stuff behind
the scenes but
it's it's interesting what he said
they're not going to chase subscriber
growth they're going to focus on
profitability these are kind of similar
words to a David zazlov has been saying
at Warner Discovery behind HBO Max right
there's a big reason why they canceled
all the HBO Max DC stuff is because they
were like oh well that's spending a ton
of money in the hopes of getting new
subscribers instead let's keep the
subscribers we have and just Farm them
for more cash whatever okay we don't
know if that's exactly what Iger is
thinking here I will say when you look
up all the data that's out there on
Disney Plus shows specifically the
Marvel and the Star Wars shows those
shows actually do not attract a lot of
new subscribers wait they do a great job
of keeping subscribers right and they
are the most popular stream shows in the
world when Loki drops or Mandalorian or
whatever right they become the number
one shows in the world but not a lot of
people are signing up for the service
just to watch those because when you
think about it every Marvel fan is
already yeah
there's no do you think there's a single
Marvel fan that's like I'm a die-hard
Marvel fan I waited to miss Marvel to
sign up for Disney plus do they have of
course not do they have Disney Plus
shows that aren't Marvel and Star Wars
that like do we know of them so yes
there's some stuff like that and
actually do you know what I think that's
a big High School Musical the musicals
do you know what is the number one uh
new subscriber getter I think still of
all time for Disney plus what Hamilton
the music
but you know why people couldn't get
tickets that's right and and you know
that was early it was early enough in
Disney plus that was you know it was
special I think that also got think
about it again if you're a hardcore Star
Wars or Marvel fan you've been a
subscriber from the jump but that was
for like the moms right or the like uh
your cousin that doesn't watch any of
this stuff but he would sign up to watch
Hamilton so all that is to say that's so
insane if you interpret it that way that
that Marvel and Disney shows or I'm
sorry Marvel and Star Wars shows do not
get new subscribers but they keep
subscribers that actually is a key to
profitability yeah that is something
where it's not driving new subscribers
but it is very profitable because you
want people to stay subscribed for the
long run now you could also flip that
profitability right there's two parts of
profit money coming in money going out
they could try to lower the costs of the
shows they're making and obviously Star
Wars shows and Marvel shows are very
expensive Zach I love economic exactly I
know this is insane I no doubt on this
stuff right and so like you could see
what they were kind of talking about
this right they want to keep every
Marvel and Star Wars fan right they need
to find new fans of stuff of other stuff
but they want to keep all of us what is
the minimum amount of Marvel and Star
Wars stuff that would keep you a Disney
plus subscriber two shows a year Well
quite honestly
you go to Disney plus I watched I I
wanted to watch into the spider-verse a
couple days ago I wanted to watch no way
home a couple days ago those are Sony
movies they're not on Disney they're on
Amazon but yeah
you I'm going to Disney plus to watch
show movies and shows that I've already
seen and loved right their catalog is
also a huge part of keeping their
subscribers especially for families or
like animated stuff I'm like watching my
nephew I turn it on it's the and also
I'm a Disney adult so I don't know what
you're gonna do hell yeah right get give
them Coco for the 50th time or whatever
right yeah but like if they're looking
to lower costs maybe they lean into that
even more and again they'll keep all the
family you got Beauty and the Beast and
one Lion King and Aladdin's on there so
everybody with a nine-year-old kid is
gonna stay subscribed forever so let me
ask you this this is something I heard
from I was looking through Facebook and
some people said they didn't go see
wakanda forever in the in the theaters
because they know in less than about 45
days especially the way of the water
coming out it's gonna hit Disney plus
yeah so now you have people again Disney
has figured out how to cut down sharing
passwords because now there's like all
four of you can't be too much longer on
one account so Disney has to figure that
way of like people are now not going to
go to theaters they're going to stay to
Disney plus they're not going to go back
to doing what they were doing in the
pandemic it's like hey here's a 29.99
release that you can watch because Black
Widow didn't work out for them yes yeah
and the pandemic has shifted a lot of
things right like uh I think there's a
pot a pessimistic and an optimistic way
to look at this let's go optimistic
first because like we're positive here
at new rockstars right we love this
stuff the positive is
again one way that like the head of of
Warner Brothers has talked about it and
kind of this was hinted at when they
made the choice to move armor Wars from
being a series to being a theatrical
maybe this is Disney being like hey
instead of spending 150 million dollars
to make Falcon Winter Soldier let's
spend 300 and make Captain America new
world order instead and have a big
theatrical release we'll make a billion
dollars at the box office and people
will still come to Disney plus to watch
it 45 days later so maybe we're looking
at a world where we see a lot more
Marvel and Star Wars and theater I mean
Star Wars especially we haven't had a
theatrical release in three years no and
I don't think there's anything else
there's nothing on this late so maybe
instead of you know more mandalorians at
the Wazoo we're going to see more stuff
into you now let's go let's go
economical with that you got the same
company where it's going to drop these
different Blockbusters from different
genres whether it be Marvel Star Wars
Avatar Indiana Jones now you gotta space
it out even more because yes all the
money comes collected with to the same
place but you want them all to make
their own Revenue total so how do you do
that then you know I'm saying like if
you get people you're using that money
with the box office for like because you
know again 45 days later so you have one
movie 45 days it goes to D plus then
here's another movie big movie in the
theaters 45 days here's another is that
how you do how you would think they
would do it and and like I I think so
that's gonna be maybe a part of their
strategy because again it's hard to
argue with I think what kind of
forever's already made 700 million
dollars to the box office yes it's two
weeks right it's hard to argue even for
a huge company like Disney dropping a
billion dollars from what kind of
forever has a huge impact on them right
so I think that that is part of it I
don't think there's a world where like
we were talking about this maybe the
specific kinds of Marvel and Star Wars
properties that they develop for Disney
plus right are like ones that keep the
fans engaged for maybe cost a little
less so is that like what we have now
yeah well but maybe I mean Loki felt
expensive yes right like so maybe we get
a little bit more Guardians holiday
those are the first ones yeah those are
the ones out the gate that were really
expensive you know now you know better
so now you're like we don't need to do
this and sorry to catch you up like you
were just saying Guardian special you
already are filming the movie you
already got everybody here it doesn't
really go outside of your budget anymore
yeah because everybody's here that you
need so now you just say let's do this
offshoot yeah and you start doing that
in 15 days that's it yeah
no you're an adult watching this when
you're eating this up
I can listen to this forever more food
for this conversation right Disney plus
is only second to Netflix when it comes
to numbers
and that is a big it is a big gap
Netflix has more than double the
subscribers of Disney plus and a big
chunk of the Disney plus subscribers are
people in India that subscribed for
Cricket uh yeah it's called star in
India and they pay like 99 cents a month
so it is like though it has a big number
of subscribers it doesn't have that much
revenue but when you talk about he's
saying we're not focused on gaining more
subscribers we're focused on Revenue
right you have the subscribers already
there it's so much harder to convert
someone who isn't already paying than it
is to lose yeah they just want to keep I
I it's like I have seven subscriptions
to [ __ ] that I I have a Squarespace
subscription great sponsor I don't have
a website right now
you're a Target customer yeah so so
Disney wants to keep the subscribers
that they have they are going to do well
this sounds mean and this is the
negative side right this is the this is
the this is the password I'm glad that
you're picking you're pivoting into
pessimism this is the pessimist approach
sorry Patty
um they could do the minimum of a
possible to keep their subscribers right
that could be their strategy in the
future uh I don't think that that's a
winning strategy what because you're
burn people and like I think iger's
coming into this company saying jpeg
already burned the Goodwill of our fans
so he doesn't want a lot of the park
stuff but that is something that they
could do well and and
real quick
2023 we're saying 2023 is probably
untouched because coven of chaos which
is the last series that we're expecting
in 2023 is already in production yeah so
they're not going to cancel Echo is is
already done uh ironheart's already done
um Loki season two is in in the works
what if X-Men 97 all that stuff they're
already in the middle of it so they're
not going to cancel or change any of
that stuff dramatically but 2024 we
might see an impact Vision Quest
um Wonder Man uh maybe a 10 Ring series
what if those two get fused together
yeah we don't know or maybe some of
these again get pivoted to a special
presentation yeah where instead of six
episodes we get kind of one maybe some
of them they're like actually we might
be able to make some more money at the
box office here let's release this to
theaters because we think theaters are
going to bounce back by then covet will
be a thing of the past we don't know
um anyways I bet let's keep an eye on
the next time we see Kevin feige making
a big announcement maybe attack
Comic-Con maybe it's that whatever right
let's see how many Disney plus series
because next year 2023 is the best
Disney plus year ever if you're thinking
about I want to also real quick is
anybody watching this show not a Disney
plus subscriber and what would it take
to get you there I kind of or are you
the kind of person that's like oh the
second andor's over I'm out or the
second She-Hulk ends I unsubscribe and
I'm gonna wait till secret Invasion
comes back that is part of their model
right is to say oh hey you know uh Thor
love and thunder dropped in August uh
and or started in September and kept you
until uh November you know it's like
part of their strategy is to trickle
things from their theatrical there's
always something there's every month
they want yeah because remember at the
beginning what was the very first thing
the very first two things we were
focused on with Disney Plus One Division
Mandalorian both yeah both back to back
yeah when Mandalorian was done a lot of
people cancel their subscriptions
because there was nothing coming that is
why we got this whole influx of we need
all this d-plus content so yeah now we
get it all and again like you said if
it's not bringing in new subscribers and
bringing in Revenue more some more
certain subscribers that's like what are
we doing yeah yeah
no if you have a final thought I was
gonna move on no that phase
into that this could be a separate
podcast because it has real World
implications of like the the content we
love like what form is that going to
take the volume of it just the last
thing 2023 is going to be awesome for
Disney plus Bob Iger will not change
that we have the most series the most
Marvel series and the most Star Wars
series next year right in addition to
three cool movies that we're excited
about and maybe we don't even know about
special presentations they haven't
announced any of those yet they'll
probably have some of those so it's like
it's going to be a great year 2024 we
don't know we'll see we don't know we'll
see speaking of things that are coming
in 2024 we hope we'll see hey Vincent
D'Onofrio is doing a little uh maybe
like a con type of thing uh he was
talking about uh his future as Kingpin
in the MCU can we roll that clip real
fast my question to you is as Kingpin
who would you love to interact or fight
in the current MCU
oh you got a lot of good ones to choose
from
I mean there's only one really end goal
and I think somebody just said
hell yeah somewhere who was that someone
yelled Spider-Man from the audience if
you missed it
um Jay you wanted to talk about this a
little bit because there have been some
rumors that both Marvel and Sony have
signed a new deal for Spider-Man movies
and they're getting close to being in
pre-pro sounds like they're good there's
a script there's a script possibly done
so that means when no way home was
happening everything was already working
for the next movie because they knew how
I was going to end Peter was going to
have his life now he has to do
everything over
how everything's going to be now we
don't know what his life is we don't
know who signed on either remember
you've had uh Jacob battle on keep
making these wherever I don't know if
I'm gonna be here I don't know Zendaya's
just saying nothing we know they have to
be here for this if this is the last I
mean they don't have to be in the whole
movie
they could be in the first half or the
back half yeah they could be at MIT
MIT or someone with each other
Williams
the black woman beats me
but yeah so like you can have so it's
said to be in pre-production so pretty
soon would more than likely fanx uh Fan
Expo in Brazil they may make an
announcement about it now that's amazing
oh yeah a leak because you know that
stuff leaks you know so I I think we are
getting that because again I would
rather see more info on what's going on
with that than a doctor strange three
right now oh absolutely yes you gave me
Charlize theronas Cleo uh clear okay
fine whatever and I'm excited but it's
like I'm not in a rush I didn't know who
she was I had to look her up but that's
why I'm like what I knew everything you
could make a pretty solid argument that
like over the last five years no
franchise has been handled better
absolutely absolutely then the
live-action Spider-Man franchise right
that even though we've had three you
could be like oh maybe the fans are a
little exhausted no no like we would
take a Spider-Man movie every other year
for the rest of our lives
59 year old Tom Holland right who got
into the spider-verse you gotta cross
the spiders coming out next year
speaking of 2023 which is really pollen
in it
rumor I think the year after that
because they they're splitting it up the
material yeah
um look I just watched into the
spider-verse again this weekend it's
such a good movie yeah I think I think
Spider-Man is my favorite character in
in all of superheroes and again if
you're just judging Halloween Halloween
costumes there's more there's more
nine-year-old kids walking around in
Spider-Man costumes than all other
Heroes combined yeah go to Comic Cons
there are always variations of
Spider-Man everywhere more than anything
who's popular that year yeah I saw I saw
15 chords this year for really no you
didn't oh I was gonna say I saw a lot of
black panther I love this especially
like this is like when you say there's
like a rumor this is happening like it's
still a pretty quiet rumor this is again
reporting any of the big Publications
it's kind of you know Whispers here and
there like if this does get announced I
mean it's gonna be huge of course right
and like in the casting because they
didn't give themselves an out to not
have Babylon right like so like to
confirm that they're in it would also be
a huge announcement even revolory people
have been asking him Tony revelry about
it and you know he's just like even
whatever happens because again flashes
in MIT as well oh yeah
hey uh sorry we didn't get some more of
your super chats we started we started
late a little bit late technically we
started on time but then we all we all
started like
I can't read it
basket Bucky Barnes ATL we always
appreciate you trash bag samil
battenfeld Christian unpronounceable
from the great white North up there we
appreciate you Christian uh Zeals me oh
that's a new one I like that name and uh
uh how do you pronounce the little guy's
name Perry Club oh Jamie Riley Jamie
Riley you have a trick name that always
makes me miss MJ 2997 uh Randy clemula
uh thank you to everybody who sent in
super chats today we were we were up
against we had so much to talk about we
were wrong it's so much to talk about
um because we were off for a week but
come back we'll be here every day this
week won't we John oh yeah we have a lot
we still didn't even cover everything I
know I teased King in an unlikely uh uh
movie I forgot we didn't we left that
started to tomorrow it's blade come back
for that
unlikely unlikely blade
um hey enter that contest to win the uh
the vest from epic hero that's in the uh
description of this video hit like And
subscribe if you already have it already
that'd be dope uh we appreciate you come
see us at La Comic-Con this Sunday and
uh thank you so much for watching thank
you guys for being here stick around on
the channel we got some cool stuff
coming out this week tomorrow Glass
Onion ending explained uh Wednesday
There's a Rick and Morty breakdown on
Friday Jessica wanted to talk about big
questions on Thursday
we'll see you later bye